yo what's good y'all boys this your boy
denzel curry make sure you check me out
on a bootleg calf podcast tune in and
stay tuned
bullet cav show special guest in here
denzel curry what's good welcome welcome
um
you know i feel like i've been trying to
interview you for like [ __ ] eight
years now so it's good to finally link
with you man listen when
i mean i think i told you this before
then like you know i was really hard at
reach you know
not reaching out to people and [ __ ] like
i just didn't do it but you know we
finally here we finally get to talk i
feel like we're uh i was talking to
somebody on your team last year but did
you have like an injury or something
like did you did you like hurt hurt some
part of your body or something and
i mean i got an injury now i know you
got injury now but
this was probably like back in like 2019
then probably because i did have a crazy
injury then because that's when i was on
tour with on billy eilish and [ __ ] i
think that's what it was yeah how's how
is that touring with billy eilish well
billy that's my dog you know she seems
super chill oh she cool as [ __ ] but like
what is that like because you're um
your stage presence is insane your music
is extremely i feel like it's built for
like live
environments right but that's a
different type of vibe right like man
it's a lot of little girls just the
whole thing with the billy honors tour
it just opened my eyes to like what i
could possibly be doing you know
so what i mean by that is like i was
doing venues and clubs and stuff like
that right right you know that's pretty
much easy for me very successfully i
might add yeah thank you thank you yes
but when
i got to do those arenas it was
different i see what kanye west was
talking about when he went on tour with
youtube like he wanted to make music for
like arenas and [ __ ] like that so with
her giving me the opportunity to open up
for her own tour
i felt like that was gangster because
like i never heard my music in that kind
of environment before
so it made me look at my music
differently
it made you kind of like
i feel like there is there is a such
thing as like making music for arenas
like we think of like people like yo
this is a festival record this is going
to go crazy in front of echo chella like
so now when you go in and you record
certain records you'll have that in mind
because you've actually
been through it yeah i mean a lot of
that [ __ ] is like synth heavy and bass
heavy you know what i'm saying and i
just want to be able to have the crowd
sing my lyrics because to be honest with
you like i'll be rapping fast and then
i'll be saying big words and people like
i'll give you all these type of
metaphors and sometimes it hit and
sometimes it miss and people be like
what the [ __ ] you talking about denzel
you know it's never like real straight
up but with just me working now i feel
like melody is always going to win like
we know songs just based off the melody
like a b c d chord you know all that
[ __ ] you could hum it and you'll be like
i know what that is you know twinkle
twinkle little star same [ __ ] how would
someone hum ultimate
so was billy eilish just a fan of you
and like what like was it her idea like
how did that happen because that's kind
of she's young you know um
all right it happened in 2016 fyf that's
when she came to my show for the first
time i'm like one of her favorite
rappers okay and i didn't even know i
was one of her favorite rappers until
she told me in 2017 because that's where
we've met officially and the first time
we met we was at the studio we was you
know supposed to work on the record it
was me her and phineas
and
we didn't even make a record we were
just
cracking jokes the whole time we went to
go get a acai bowl go eat we were just
you know
talking to each other just you know just
cutting up then our relationship started
to build more and more over time is you
know as time progressed and [ __ ]
and basically you know she came to the
studio and worked on sirens which is
with me and jed on a taboo on record
yeah yeah you know shout out to billy
she seems to be like someone who's like
despite all the fame and being one of
the biggest you know pop stars in the
world she seems pretty like every time i
see her talking or do an interview she
seems like a humble cool chick bro she's
down on earth as [ __ ] and i think she
wears jinko's which is awesome i don't
even know what that is but jingle pants
jinko you don't remember jinx oh how old
are you well dude yeah 27. yeah you
don't remember jingles here's the thing
man giant pockets juggalos used to wear
them oh you talking about like insane
clown posse type [ __ ] no
you don't remember the jinko pants huge
legs and the pockets were like the size
of this tv hell no oh man
bruh they was in florida wearing them
somewhere
i wasn't wearing them they're probably
wearing them in the middle of like polk
county had them for sure you know what
i'm saying i don't know about
not day counting not date county
you are a pioneer though i want to give
you love because um
i would always be interviewing some of
these uh you know i i feel like south uh
south florida in general
has really had um its
its moment is still happening but it
kind of really kicked off like where
nationally like some of the bigger
artists
were all from you know obviously kodak
black is one of those guys uh x uh
little pump you know we can go on and on
and on but i do feel like you and uh
the raider clan really kicked off that
entire
just that whole entire wave out of
out of south florida i mean of course
and i'm a good respect whereas do you
know like space goes perp really was
like the driving force for that [ __ ] at
the time when he first came out and him
and rocky was running together until the
beef happened but when it came down to
raider clan and the whole aesthetic and
everything before we disbanded like we
was really trying to bombard the
industry on some [ __ ] like when we were
young and we was all in high school at
the time like y'all laid the roots for
all this other [ __ ] that's going on you
know what i'm saying for sure of course
all that [ __ ] came from us yeah a
hundred percent and and uh yeah you
definitely you need to get you get your
flowers fat yeah it's crazy because when
you think about we were just talking
about it yesterday the asap rocky's
space ghost perp thing
um such an unfortunate thing because
it's like what what if that never would
have happened like you know what i'm
saying like man listen if that would
have never happened you know we probably
would have had a strong hold on the game
right now you know what i'm saying
because we was like the driving force of
the culture of both
raider clan and asap
yeah and a lot of the aesthetic and a
lot of the vibe i feel like that rocky
had for the asap mob
you know was heavily influenced by the
raider clan [ __ ] as well yeah i mean
when it came down to everything that was
going on and then you know when perpin
rocket was going through it and [ __ ] and
you know
black land radio 66.6 did come out
before i heard live love asap or pesos
you get what i'm saying yeah so
i still have respect for rocky i still
respect rocky to this day you know what
i'm saying but i give credit where on
creditors do if it wasn't for perp and
it wasn't for raider clan i wouldn't
have a platform to be denzel curry you
feel what i'm saying right so i'ma
always give respect to them regardless
of what the [ __ ] me and this [ __ ]
purple go through right you know what i
mean
what's your relationship like what is
perp up to do do you have a relationship
with him anymore
i don't know i don't talk to food like
that he don't talk to me i don't talk to
him but we still you know
he'll big me up and then he'll
disrespect me in the same way
probably in the same week yeah you know
but it's all love from my point right
and i hope it's all love from him and it
is what it is well i was telling you
this man i do feel like
for as you're s you're very successful
um
but i still feel like somehow you're
like underappreciated in the industry
because i feel like you're one of the
most versatile rappers artists period in
the last decade or so
you know like um
listening to i just listened to your
well
99 of your new album i'm like man like
the [ __ ] that you can do
between melodies between the fast rap
[ __ ] between the boom bap [ __ ]
it's um there's just not a lot of people
who can cover all those bases and cover
them very well and organically if that
makes sense well a lot of that [ __ ] get
lost in translation because i'm not
popular
if you want to be real you know what i'm
saying like you're not pop music yeah
i'm not pop music so you gotta really
dig in the crevice to be like oh i
listen to denzel curry like you know my
music was catered to a niche crowd you
dig yeah and
me when it come down to this album i
just want everybody it doesn't matter if
you're a denzel curry fan or not i want
you to feel that [ __ ]
period is this the first album that you
took that approach with yeah i took my
feelings first before i took me what i
was gonna think about rapping about
it was my feelings
like whatever i felt i know people have
the same feelings so i'm gonna write
what i feel
instead of writing what i know
i like that i like that
i would just learn that you do muay thai
yeah you've been doing it since 2017
but if a little bit of background calf
a lot of my brothers
like my brother's is you know
been in the streets and [ __ ] like that
i'm the only one out of my brothers that
never been to jail
you know what i'm saying i lost one of
my brothers but the brother i did lose
he was a backyard fighter back in the
day with like kimbo slice and man those
got our 5 000. yeah all of them videos
are crazy and that was all in miami yeah
and there was a movie that he was in
called dog fights so i'm just letting
you putting you up on game
and i was also in the movie too but that
was like 12 year old denzel and if you
go on youtube to this day and you look
up like fights like level martinez
versus alfonso watching all those
backyard fights
crazy if you look at tree versus uh mike
you're gonna see me there in a white tee
holding the camera up she used to be in
the backyard i used to be in the
backyard like dead ass like i'm not even
gonna sit here a lot to you how would
they organize those things cause bruh
like my brother would just come in the
room and he'd be like hey you wanna come
over here and see me fight and i'll be
like all right you know i will go there
it will be in piranha in the middle of
piranha
it will be a little green house and a
big-ass backyard and they will check you
at the gate to see if you got guns
knives whatever and if you got guns and
knives whatever you got to go put that
[ __ ] in your car and then you come in
they check kids too
so you go in there you know what i'm
saying and there'd be a ring in there at
first it was like a box ring at first it
didn't have no ring at all i was gonna
say some of the videos was just there's
just no ring yeah it was just people
crowding around yeah at first they
didn't have a ring then they had a ring
then they had an octagon then they had a
triangle that was like the final
you know and just being back there and
just watching all these fights you
hearing the beef go down with people and
[ __ ] you know and you're just like yo
what the [ __ ] is going on like you see a
big ass dude like oh i'm gonna get you
[ __ ] i'm getting like what the [ __ ]
like right yeah i'm 12 years old looking
at all this [ __ ] like yo this is like
some real fighting [ __ ] like this some
real tournament [ __ ] and i'm watching
people get knocked the [ __ ] out i'm
watching blood just
gushing just out of my brother's nose
did your brother ever fight kimbo no
hell no
kimbo was already like in the ufc around
this time okay
and kimbo used to roll with each other
until they kind of fell out you know
what i'm saying
and
around that time it was just dada and
what i was doing in the backyard but
kimbo was before that you know what i
mean so
you know long live kimbo you feel me so
that was kind of the origins of you that
got you interested in learning how to
fight i mean i had to learn how to fight
i had too many brothers to not know how
to fight how many brothers do you have
well one of them passed it was four of
us okay you know what i'm saying and
were you the youngest i'm the youngest
oh yeah i mean you got to learn how to i
got to learn how to fight i was like
like
he's getting bullied outside the house
and getting bullied inside the house so
i had to learn how to fight you the way
i go
so in 2017 you take a muay thai yeah um
what do you kind of give us the rundown
on like
just the muay thai [ __ ] cause you were
you're very passionate about it well i
don't think a lot of people know because
you was you're very you know your [ __ ]
man well when it comes down to muay thai
man i like
well i stopped smoking weed right
and this was back in 2017 i felt like my
life was gonna be boring because i
wasn't like smoking right and then i was
like you know i might as well stop
drinking too so i just looked out i
remember i was doing martial arts with
my brothers and stuff like that when i
was younger so i'm like you know when i
find a time
you know if i get enough money i'm just
going to go back into martial arts and i
said that when i first started rapping
and [ __ ] because i stopped doing it
and then
next thing you know i was like oh
there's a muay thai um place right down
the street it was five star martial arts
go there i signed up guy signed me up i
looked at the class and then i went in
the next day started doing it got my
girl to do it
and then um
i just kept doing it ever since
and it's been five years right yeah it's
been five years i can't train not
because i got a tour of acl but like
um is it like a did you get belts like
what's like what's your belt level well
in thailand they don't really have a
ranking system okay okay you know what
i'm saying because they've been doing it
since they was kids
they get it on project but that's like
cut off like addresses that's what they
would wear right right before they go
it's like it brings them a good look
but
in
like the ranking system at the school
they will rank it like how they will
rank jiu jitsu you get what i'm saying
you start off white you know you might
get a stripe you might end up at blue
you might get a stripe you might end up
at purple you might get a stripe you
might end up at brown
um and then all the way to black like
brown to black you feel me
how serious people
rank their um schools differently though
how far would you take the muay thai
thing because i don't we know like uh
you know we got a friend d smoke uh who
was like a semi-professional boxer
before he really started popping as a
rapper so like would you like how far
would you take it i mean i wanted to
compete
to be honest i wanted to compete to see
where my skill level was at you know to
see um if i'm pretty you know
see where i'm at and see where i need to
improve on you know what i mean
but that's how far i was willing to take
it like to do a couple on matches
but
other than that it was just um
i just like doing it for my sanity to be
real it's like it's almost like their
therapy
have you been to thailand yes how was
that thailand is dope it's like very
did you go out there and like watch muay
thai like and it's because you know you
see these like youtube videos of like
the muay thai fights in thailand i mean
like lupini stadium stuff like that [ __ ]
so crazy though
yeah i mean i haven't been able to do
that but my boy kashan he been trying to
get me to go to um go back to thailand
and like go to the gyms because you got
to know somebody to have that connection
to the gym just to get in there yeah i
mean it's open but you gotta i would
much rather know somebody who'd been
there before and know these gyms
be like hey just pull up
yeah no that's dope man um you you also
obviously are a big ufc fan oh hell yeah
who's your like if you had to give me
your goat like top three fighters ever
ever since since you've been watching
since i've been watching okay all right
i gotta put um anderson silver in there
anderson was the guy who broke his leg
right there yeah yeah
bro yeah he raw as [ __ ] um
this is gonna be controversial i'm gonna
put jon jones up there shout out to jon
jones he loves cocaine can i can i shout
out john this is documented by the way
um
and
as of right now recently
um
style been style bender yeah that was my
three but when it comes down to like
overall like i have a lot of favorite
fighters that are like in the women's
division is valentina shepchenko
like she be [ __ ] people up like there
was a match where she was [ __ ] this
lady up so bad i was waiting for the
referee to stop it the man would not
stop it it took her to choke the girl
out some of those hurt us stopped for
him to stop the match i forget which
which female fight it was i think it was
last year the year before where the
girl's head was lumped oh yeah you
remember that hell yeah i was like oh
wait wait this happened last year right
yeah i was actually at that fight
no no this happened two years ago yeah
it was like it was like a year or two
ago yeah it happened in 2020 before the
whole pandemic yo that was wally zane
versus um joanna joe check i remember
that fight i was dead at that fight i
was watching that fight her head was
i was like there is she gonna be all
right like no she was okay that [ __ ] her
head went back to normal but that was
one of the best fights i've ever seen in
the women's division ever
that shit's crazy
that kind of head trauma can't be uh i
don't know man that's why i mean i think
like uh
i feel like fighters peaks are usually
shorter
than like any other type of athlete you
know yeah there's a lot of wear and tear
on your body it's like a short peak like
even if you think of like conor mcgregor
like what he probably had like a
four-year run as like that that dude and
then you know i feel like he's still the
name he's still the draw he's still
gonna sell pay-per-views but like in
terms of like
he's you know he's he's lost what he's
lost uh he's been losing right yeah but
i'm a fan of his striking you know it's
kind of hard when you're a striker like
wrestlers is like the answer to that
so if you're a striker
a bad matchup for you is a wrestler
against a wrestler they'll tire you out
is that what happened with the the maga
dude and uh um jorge mazzada yeah
you know what's crazy yeah i think so
cause he has wrestling on his side you
know what i mean and monster dog is a
striker you get me
so
it's between that match-up
you know i would love to go for a
monster doll i would love for him to win
but i knew kobe was going to win because
he got wrestling
like wrestlers are strong man strong
people um on this album i feel like
there's some moments that are extremely
uh vulnerable extremely honest like um
i guess for you like
how much of this album was like
you had to get some [ __ ] off your chest
i guess all of it yeah because it felt
that way especially the intro
like that was just laying my demons out
on front street like all my flaws out on
front off the rip yeah i don't want a
sugar coat [ __ ] i know where i [ __ ] up
at you feel me so i wanted to put that
on front street so people know like hey
i'm human like i'll be doing [ __ ] up
[ __ ] and i'd be going through [ __ ] up
[ __ ]
you know that doesn't mean i can't
change that doesn't mean you can't
change either if you did something if
you made bad choices in your day
that doesn't stop you from making good
choices later you know what i mean
that's real and i just wanted to show my
own self on front street where i didn't
hide behind clever bars or i didn't hide
behind a personality i just wanted to
show you denzel
yeah there yeah 100
that's what it felt like what are the
things that like because you've
obviously um
had a cra i mean what's it been
about 10 years
10-year run yeah and you still are here
you're still very successful more
successful than ever you're still very
relevant um
you're saying you're not you know you
you you know some people 10 years in you
could tell like it's just industry
hasn't been good on you you know what i
mean um what are the things that you've
obviously you you mentioned uh muay thai
being a former therapy but is there
anything else that you've kind of been
able to adapt to just kind of help you
deal with just the anxiety or just the
pressures of being an artist or
just
when you're feeling down throughout my
time through a quarantine and stuff like
that actual therapy was helping me like
talking to a therapist talking actually
to a therapist right was it on zoom
it was sometimes it was on zoom and
sometimes it was in person but i would
have to wear masks right and i'll have
to get the little clicky thing yeah yeah
like oh you got a regular temperature
but yeah it was that
it was martial arts
and it was just being close with god
like trying to like find your connection
back with god and writing writing on
this album that helps a lot you know
what i mean yeah right it's kind of like
a journal type thing right yeah it was
like diary entries yeah no it's dope um
you were saying you do hot yoga too we
were talking about hot yoga man hey you
can't be just putting my [ __ ] out on
front street like a [ __ ] doing yoga
which khalifa was so passionate about me
doing hot yoga yesterday yeah i'm just
[ __ ] with you but um
yeah but how yoga is the [ __ ]
huh yeah i want to do i want to try that
and i want to try a sensory deprivation
tank that's when you sit in like a tank
and it's a water water
i heard like if you
sit in that [ __ ] even if you're
hallucinating yeah even if you're not on
anything you could it's like a natural
like
plus and it i don't know yeah it is i
mean
the rapper you know who daylight is yeah
of course yeah daylight was telling me
about that [ __ ] years ago
it was like sensory deprivation daylight
shout out to daylight daylight's an
amazing mc yeah you know it's crazy me
and him are 10 years apart and his
birthday is like a few days before mine
nice guy too super nice guy i remember
in phoenix he had a battle at the
celebrity theater and he shed on stage
which was interesting wait you was there
for that
i was not there but all my friends i'm
from phoenix so i had like seven of my
homies like yo bro we're at this [ __ ]
battle and dude started [ __ ] on i
was like what what
the spawn guy
you know what's crazy nobody knows
that's where his own face tattoo came
from
yes it's chapel from spawn yeah
hey shout out to spawn
you know what's crazy i heard they're
remaking the uh they're gonna do a new
spawn movie they should because the
first one was good but it wasn't like
great yeah they saying they trying to
get jamie foxx for it
i don't know about that you don't think
so maybe
the first one i was like as a kid i was
like yeah that's five as an adult i'm
like this ain't that far just like that
movie right there
billy when you when i was a kid it was
the best movie ever and then when i like
really started like find out about like
you know what cinnamon like i'm like
okay visually it's amazing but
the story the story of belly is terrible
super terrible but you watch it and it's
like there's moments in the movie that
are like iconic and like that's all that
like as like a 10 year old whose
favorite rapper
from the
yeah
like the intro where they come in and
the shit's in their eyes and they get
the guns from the toilet but it's
probably
the in my opinion
the best worst movie ever
for nostalgic purposes there are movies
that are like that like the best worst
movie oh there's a lot of shitty uh good
movies
i guess we'll call them shitty what's
another one damn
that's another one every movie matthew
mcconaughey has been in except dallas
buyers club uh
i you know i never got into matthew
mcconaughey movies man [ __ ] i used to
think daredevil like that movie was
wrong until i realized like i don't like
the way that ben affleck acts
he's in a lot of those movies we're
talking about yeah he's in a lot of
those except the town
was raw i give him the town shout out to
the homies slain yeah the town was crazy
geely with jlo they say is like the
worst movie ever but i as a kid because
i used to be obsessed with j.lo
i was like i don't get it it's not it's
not terrible but belly definitely
terrible not as bad as belly too billy
jones who was starring starring the game
terrible i thought boosie was in that
movie
i hope he is i don't remember no it was
starting the game
oh my god if boozy was in there and
didn't make the [ __ ]
vhs cover because i had it i never seen
belly too so i can't even tell you
that's not it i wonder if they just
is like someone shot it on their iphone
or
i don't know this was like 12 years ago
shout out to belly yeah
movies with rappers in them you know
what movie i like that guy
like i like get richard.trying
solid movie that's a solid movie i like
um southpaw
southpaw was doing well those are 50
cent movies right
yeah uh i mean eight mile was good um
but then great we just went through uh
we just talked about this the other day
there were so many random like when i
was growing up they used to just
put [ __ ] out um
and and like there was a movie called
ticker
and it was nas and steven seagal and
this other dude but they had nas front
and center on the cover like he had a
real part in the movie it was like
starring and it said nas like right in
the middle and i was like nah is my
favorite rapper right so i buy the
[ __ ] dvd bill maddox my [ __ ]
he's in the movie for 30 seconds
deadass deadass but steven seagal it's
steven seagal nas and some other guy but
it was like the cover of the movie it's
just nas stephen cigals on the left and
this other white dudes on the right so
you thinking oh [ __ ] nas is in this
[ __ ] let's go hey romeo must die
was hard dmx exit wounds was fire too oh
that [ __ ] was hard cradle to the grave
was hard the grave was fire
then there's like random ones like uh
you know
yeah there's a lot shout out to a killer
season cameron yeah killer season was
funny that masterpiece [ __ ] i got the
hook
on my back b i got the hook up master p
was solid master p had a had a little
wave with the movies for uh didn't you
make that movie hot boys with the
shocker yeah
i remember that [ __ ] silk the shocker
best worst rapper ever
it ain't my fault as my [ __ ] best worst
rapper ever hitting my fault is pretty
hard quite possibly the belly of rappers
soak the shocker i ain't gonna sit here
and don't i was just dming him and i i i
want to interview him because i really
would like to just talk to him and be
like dude there was like 90 days when i
was 11. i thought you're the greatest
rapper alive because i had a no limit
chain and
i had one of those
from the middle of the mall
i had a no limit chain and a wu-tang
chain you had a wu-tang drink yeah
they were like 12 oh turn green
have you seen the new batman movie no
not yet don't spoil it okay okay it's
really good but don't spoil it i won't
you seen doom
no no it's everyone
everyone who's seen it
that i know says it's very uh
it's just like one of those movies where
you're like 45 minutes in and you're
like what the [ __ ] is even going on
right now
it's not like that though i haven't
watched it don't knock it till you tried
it did you play the game
dune yeah no
i don't know brad i don't know
dune was a game
it was
it was a game you said doom
dune
[Music]
was a book it was a game on pc
was it yes
google that [ __ ] maybe i'm tripping dune
the game it was like a pc game
idris elba's in it right what
wait and what and doom isn't he in dune
hell no uh then i don't know
i know it's it's in a book it's on hbo
max right now
it was on hbo max isn't it a game oh
yeah it is i see a game they have a
bunch of games
yeah it's a pc game from like the 90s
yeah
that's crazy no for the from the 90s
the only games i played on pc was like
half life
only games i played on pc was [ __ ]
oregon trail i don't even know what that
is [ __ ] we used to get that free day at
school they put you on that with that
floppy disk you play that oregon trail
you you go hunting
kill you a buffalo feed your family
until your daughter gets a snake bite
and then she dies oh [ __ ] the goal is to
get to oregon
you never played organ trail no oh man
when i was coming up [ __ ] was
playing runescape and [ __ ] i never
played that [ __ ]
yeah i just i didn't have a computer
until i was like 15 so
yeah i never got into the online gaming
did you play do you do game now like on
on the on the pc or on the nah i play on
the playstation you play the playstation
yeah what is your go to uh ghost of
tsushima yo
so
i don't have time for anything in life
so i i have this thing where i buy games
and i just don't play
so i have like every
i mean my son plays them so shout out to
my son aiden i mean i see you play the
mortal kombat because you got it in here
yeah i mean it's but that's legendary
though like yeah who doesn't play mortal
kombat right but that game i bought it
and it's the one game i haven't that
game in the spider-man game i'm um i
haven't touched yet the spider-man game
is pretty fast i know so those are like
the two games like whenever i have like
time to breathe i want to try to play my
son says that that way you never played
a new mortal kombat
yeah i played with my kid that's easy
though that's easy to hop in do some
matches and you know yeah the other [ __ ]
you gotta really be that the ghost of
what is it ghost of sushi that [ __ ] you
gotta be committed to
that [ __ ] is hard bro cause this is a
whole story my son says it might be the
best game ever it's one of the best
games i ain't gonna say it's the best
game he's like it's up there you know
for me it's because you got that new god
of war that came out the first the first
metal gear solid is my favorite game
ever i never played metal gear solid
never played it i know who um snake is
and everything but i never played muddy
first one bro super smash brothers was
my [ __ ]
super smash bros is amazing yeah i think
um
there's a new game
is it elder ring
[Music]
i heard i heard about that it's supposed
to be coming out right
elden ring or nah it's out um someone we
just knew who was saying that they were
playing it oh big crit
last night was telling us he's like i'm
i'm addicted to this that's another
person who don't get the credit they
deserve i told him that yesterday i said
hey crit for what it's worth you're one
of the greatest rappers of all time did
you not hear crit was here or returning
forever i have quit was here on vinyl i
was in high school bumping that [ __ ] of
course
trust me i started liking big crit you
know i ain't gonna say i listen to him
not right but when i was listening to
him like glass house on um where's this
project on cushion orange juice
[ __ ] was hard and then he came out with
that crit was here
and he came out with the um returner
forever returner forever was my that's
my favorite one that was one of the best
albums of that year whatever that
whatever
2010
it's probably one of my favorite albums
of the 2010s shout out to crit uh yeah
yeah we had a dope interview yesterday
yo we got to take a break in the
interview real quick tell you about our
folks at my bookie man this is my
favorite time of the year to gamble i
love gambling on sports and if you've
been thinking about putting your toe
into the pool come and join me and my
bookie okay right now we're doing a
promotion and my bookie is crazy when
you sign up for a new account and you
make your first deposit they will match
that deposit up to a thousand dollars it
is march madness the ncaa tournament is
here the brackets is getting filled out
what i need y'all to do also is go on to
my bookie when you sign up they got
their my bracket promotion going on it's
pretty crazy so essentially you sign up
for my bracket first place grand prize
winner gets a bitcoin a whole bitcoin
second place get some crazy ass nft
that's worth a [ __ ] ton of money
i don't know [ __ ] about nfts third place
hundred thousand dollars in cash and
prizes so what are you doing go to my
bookie right now man get in on some of
this march madness some of this nba
action i wonder what the odds were on
tom brady coming back from retirement
sheesh mybookie.ag
use that promo code bootleg
b-o-o-t-l-e-g one word when you sign up
and your first deposit will be matched
up to a thousand dollars in free money
let's get back to the interview yo it's
crazy because you're like your kind of
class of hip-hop
you were like right before
a lot of um
you know
you were on the same shows with a lot of
these kids i think the first um big show
i might have saw you on was the
first or second rolling loud
was it the second rolling loud there was
like a second yeah it was the second
rolling loud i dj'd it was the one that
was in wynwood um
and that was the first one and no that
was the second one that was the first
one no because i didn't there was two of
them well the first one had schoolboy q
headlining and uh and travis yeah i
didn't go to that one i was there that
was the one that rained yeah yeah my
cousin was working a dope the second one
i dj that and that was the one it was a
little wayne of future headlining
and it was in wynwood that was in 2016
or 15. it's only 16 16. it was 2016
2016. yeah because 2015 was but you were
you were on the um
the other stage but it was crazy because
it was like 21 savage was super young
and i remember he was i think he went on
before you but just in terms of like the
class of like hip hop you are
like i feel like you are kind of like
right before
um when things get started to get really
in my opinion uh
not to my liking i suppose i look at
like 2017 2018 like rap is like
the dark ages
uh i can't i can't even call it the dark
ages because you got some gems and no no
there's gems i'm not saying everything
but in terms of like just some of the
stuff labels were signing oh
you know like we would have like guys
like
kid buu coming to to the station and
this guy was like the whole reason he
got signed is because he went viral for
saying he was like a clone or like
there was instagram kids get like uh
support supreme patty got offered a deal
from 300. i don't think it takes that
much to get signed nowadays because you
just got to have an image and [ __ ] and
you can make a cool song or whatever but
my thing is is like i feel like 2017
2018
it was rough because
i would just be like what the [ __ ] are
these labels seen in some of these like
it was just i'm gonna lie the clout area
yeah that's what i was eating
peak cloud era man it was a cloud era
and i'm so glad that it like
kind of has faded away a bit it was
the way it faded out was pretty horrible
what do you mean like people dying from
overdoses oh yeah
yeah
you know what i'm saying i think the
clout era ushered back in the gangsta
rap era because
right now like i feel like this is a
gangster rap era it's like happening all
over again yeah think about estg and and
yo and like i mean a lot of those guys
they're the biggest dudes they're
getting the biggest bags um dark you
know we can go but yeah it's crazy
because
you're like you probably knew a lot of
these dudes and
i i you know just in terms of like the
drug
[ __ ] in
hip-hop man it was it was just it's just
crazy to think of all the talent that we
lost over the last i mean a lot of these
guys that you know that we lost in
hip-hop were guys that i met back in the
day i mean
x if you know our history x used to live
with me that's one
you know we lost what year was that that
was um x lived with me in 2016.
and then he started to live with bruno
in like 2017 around that time and then
he blew up
well actually it was later that year it
was like 2016 2017. yeah so for people
who don't know because i'm not totally
um
hip to i knew you guys were cool but
like give me the history of unx because
at that time i'm sure i mean
i would get into it yeah but you know i
talked to everybody about like
you know x's legacy and i'm just trying
to build my own [ __ ] you know i respect
that i respect that you know everybody
know
tons of information about x already
that's fair that's fair you feel what
i'm saying like they actually recycle
stories about x nowadays because they
want to know more about them but
my time with him is what i told other
interviewers and [ __ ] so what what about
the biggest misconception about him
you live with somebody you really get to
know him you know i mean [ __ ]
i like what you see is what you get
that's whatever you saw
is what you got that's how he was
um
how do you feel about where florida is
right now in the game because now i feel
like it's not only i mean before it was
like miami dade county
you know uh
it was really a southern florida south
florida vibe that was holding down the
state but now
the whole state is lit yeah the whole
state is orlando's popping
jacksonville's popping tampa's on the on
the way up you know there's some artists
in tampa that are dope but yeah like you
ever heard of i am douchey i heard of
him yeah yeah yeah i am dope she's this
girl but
like wait i don't know she's a girl she
um i think she's on td now right now
that's the girl that they just signed
yeah they just signed her like a week
ago right uh i don't think it was a week
ago but but they just announced that
they signed her oh they did yeah i think
they just announced it but yeah she
straight out of tampa too like you know
what i'm saying i remember when i first
met her and she was like i came to your
show back in like 2007 i was like what
those city shows were crazy yeah so i
was just thinking to myself like damn
but the fact that florida's gonna rise
right now like i just embraced it all
you know what i'm saying it's not just
south florida doing something you feel
me like just opening that door for
florida regardless of how it sounds like
it could be ratchet it could be beef and
whatever it is right right right you
know i'm saying you know you got glock 9
you got hot boy you guys spot him got
him you got um younger neighs julio
spinner bins
uh
you know what i'm saying
i am douchey taliban duda from tampa's
dope yeah you got all these people
that's going on you know what i'm saying
it's crazy as [ __ ] when you realize a
lot of these guys
rob wave is tight too saint pete
it's crazy because he's such a star
we've been i'll just be forgetting he's
from saint pete cause i lived in saint
pete for three years it's just crazy i
got family in st pete shout out to saint
pete man yeah man it's a vibe until it's
not
i think florida is a vibe too
crazy is like
when you from miami like we don't
associate with the rest of florida is so
funny that's real i mean the miami i
mean i feel like miami's such a melting
pot um
it's really like only a few other places
that remind me of like just the
like
new york is like that like depending on
where you are in new york you're like oh
i'm miami is so
little haiti there's the the cube in
there i mean it's just such a huge
melting pot it's such a dope there's so
much culture in miami it's like you know
a lot of people wouldn't even expect
that because they just think of the
beach and they think of like south beach
you know
miami as a whole is
it's like a cultural hub for a lot of a
lot of people like i love my it's my
favorite city in the united states
besides my hometown yeah and oh can't
forget i don't play that boy zay that's
my boy he coming out the city he wrote
too
yo um it was dope when
you and ross ended up finally working
together
um
because it was dope to see ross embrace
the the newer generation of what's going
on in miami how important was that for
you just like as well i mean i just felt
like it's a passing of torching [ __ ]
yeah you know what i'm saying with ross
but raw still got stuff in the chamber
that like he's still doing stuff you
know what i mean and you know i've been
listening to raw since he was white po
boy
shout out to po boy you know like when
flo ryder briscoe and ross was all
rolling together and [ __ ] but me and my
brothers like we like we love ross even
we listen to ross
like teflon dawn deeper than rap porter
miami we are new ross we knew ross was
raw and triple see his album was fire
cartel was hard
and he was putting on for the city shout
out to breed like i [ __ ] with bree
reed gun plays cause bree messed with my
boy um soldier living true that's my
[ __ ] poochie
and um we pretty much like connected
through poochy because we both [ __ ] with
poochie heavy gucci poochie is this the
same poochie that used to manage ross or
is this a different boot no it's a
different pooch okay okay different
poochies in miami yeah but you gotta
call them soldier living true so okay
okay yeah don't wanna mess that up don't
don't don't [ __ ] that up uh
shout out to gunplay though gunplay is
that [ __ ] gunplay is a rapper's
rapper a rapper's rapper rapper's rapper
remember that song power circle nah but
i was like you ever heard her take this
of course take this take this to your
brain
where he's got the white girl and he's
like
i'm like dude i show that video to
people all the time i'm like y'all want
to see the craziest flagrant ass music
video yo i'mma say it is gunplay he's
talking about being high on coke he's
paranoid as [ __ ] in the video
he's got the white chick and he's like
taking money out of her spandex that
[ __ ] was so crazy he was like [ __ ] we
living in hell how to [ __ ] you the
reverend i was like damn this [ __ ] raw
like gun play like listening to that
listening all on you rolling with waka
flocka yeah single-handedly him and waka
flocka is the reason why i wanted to
grow dreads in the first place that's
crazy you know member cartoons and
cereal with gunplay kendrick just talk
about this [ __ ] this morning
killed that [ __ ] i'm so mad that that's
not on dsps
man that [ __ ] was so raw yeah yo gun
play
yo salute gun play man i know he chopped
i know he done yapped the dress but like
he had a uh yeah there was a record on
self made too
called power soaker was the intro and it
was gunplay ross
stally wale kendrick and meek and it was
just like he kicked it off and it was
like it's probably my favorite uh my
favorite gun played gunblade be snapping
yeah it's i would like to see gunplay
like do movies or like
i don't know host a podcast or
you know maybe do like the sidewalk talk
[ __ ] that they're doing in new york with
nems the bing bong guy but like have him
in miami like
just
because he's so f he's such a character
like he's a and he's like a good ass i
mean very anime he's always been super
cool like when i met him so shout out to
gunplay me damn every time i see gunplay
is love you know so everybody should go
watch to take this video right now on
youtube and the one thing it the one
thing about gunplay is people don't even
know like out of miami rappers that's my
favorite miami rapper that's crazy
gunplay is my favorite miami rapper i
like him more than i like ross that's
wild and ross is talented as [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying best
ear for beats ever maybe
it's up there it is up there but gunplay
is like just like rawness like that's
what i love miami rappers there's
yourself there's ross there's gun play
obviously trick daddy training trina
city girls shout out to the city girls
uh
um kiddo marv major9
um who else
there's a lot there's a lot coming out
the city on bruno o'malley
uh face hood
from broward is he from broward yeah
from broward okay broward county it's
totally separate yeah because that's
where fort lauderdale is right yeah yeah
yeah okay
all right
i gotta still give it to ross
and i think i think ross is like the
10th best rapper of all time i made a
list then i had ross at number 10 and i
know that's high for a lot of people
that is high but if you listen to teflon
don and
uh deeper the rap you can't tell me
those aren't certified classics those
are classic ass albums i agree and
i mean
just the consistency bro like he's still
going the flow is butter
what he brought to the game is
i mean he's he's in my i always say like
10 he's he's top 10. and
i put him a 10. i like ross because he
brought something different to miami you
know what i'm saying
definitely he really brought something
different because really prior to that
like if you think of trick daddy trina
the slip and slide era flow rider that
[ __ ] was just not like like i feel like
ross embodied like
what we thought of miami when we saw
scarface but like an updated version of
like some boss like kingpin like it just
was like it just to me it it properly
displayed that side of the aesthetic of
miami as to where like trina and trick
were there was a whole other aesthetic
of miami that's like super turnt up and
what's your favorite miami strip club i
don't go to strip clubs
ever like never
wow [ __ ] i want to let me tell you
you're wifed up right yeah okay okay
shout out to wifey shout out to wifey
yeah but um [ __ ] i do not go to strip
clubs did you have a bad experience well
no i just don't go
not even for the food
why would i go g5 has great wings so
does tootsies but tootsie's got the
fried lobster tail with seafood rice
like i don't want to go in there and
then i just be like oh [ __ ] i went to
school with this [ __ ] like i don't you
know what i'm saying but the food is
good last time i went in
in a strip club my cousin y'all y'all
took me to the strip club
i thought you were gonna say her cousin
was dancing nah she was hell
no that would have been [ __ ] up
because you go in there not knowing and
she don't know you're coming in no
that's happened to me my boy went to a
strip club and saw his sister i swear to
[ __ ] god this [ __ ] happened like 10
years ago that's crazy
can't can't beat me though but like
i went to the strip club with my cousin
just you know because she was linking up
with a family friend over there so we i
was like you know i'm gonna slide with
you you know what i mean right i just
went in there
she you know chopped it up with a family
friend and then dipped out ran in the
ball greasy paul green
ball grizzy told the dj i was the other
dj i was like we got this little curry
in the building i was just like nah
[ __ ] i'm going home
like
he was on the little duval record right
yeah yeah yeah i thought that was dope
to see him kind of like
because like i'm like man bald grizzy
been doing this thing for a long time
and that record was like top five at
radio so it was dope to like just look
at my best life yeah shout out to dude
shout out to lil duvall man hey uh you
had t you got so let's talk about this
album when does the album actually come
out because on march 25th okay so we got
a few weeks but um so we'll hold on to
this until closer to the album but uh
you got some dope features on this
project but the t-pain feature
just was
super unexpected because i'm listening
to the album and the version of the
early that i have doesn't have the
features on it so i'm just pressing play
and i'm like yo this [ __ ] is hard and
then oh [ __ ] see pain yeah yeah t-pain
was that an easy act like pain is the
coolest mother i'm real tight with pain
i've been like pain is my guy so
people like he's the most humble if he
[ __ ] with you he [ __ ] he's the
chillest dude i've met for sure so far
it's out of him and thundercat and fly
low
yeah yeah i'm saying so what was the t
pain like like like when you cut that
record did you specifically say like
i need to pay no this will happen when i
cut the record i went to the cave to
work with kenny beets okay you know what
kenny b says right so
i work with kenny beatz at his own
studio you guys have a joint project
yeah yeah unlocked yeah like when we
together the duo is unlocked okay
produce all right he's incredible i've
been trying to get him on the show he
like went on his twitch and like
played a part of my interview talking
about how dopey is it was like we made
it and i was like damn and i'm like all
right we'll come on the show then
you might get connected yeah
i'll talk to kenny man no he's a legend
but continue but yeah so i was at kenny
b studio this was like early 2020
this is where i just went there and we
wanted to work on some tracks like you
know
and um he was playing beats and
everything then
he he played um
he was like he played something he
played the on the sample of troubles
okay
and then i just just started writing to
it as he was making a beat
and i only wrote the hook so i was like
got some trouble with that these drugs
can't [ __ ] we might struggle because
life's a [ __ ] they get happy when your
ass get rich blowing money cause our bag
ain't [ __ ] so he heard it and he was
like yo just go in the studio bro just
go in so i'm like alright i go in the
studio i lay it down i lay down the
verse i laid out two verses
and
basically you know he was just like this
is dope i sent it to my management it
was like oh this [ __ ] five this down in
the third like we like this this is
gonna be the hit i know this is gonna be
the hit
and then i'm just like yeah whatever
[ __ ] so
i remember um i was reaching out to
people at this point because like i
wasn't working as much with f and z
anymore
and i was just reaching out to people
seeing who was gonna hit me back and i
was reaching out specifically to
producers
not even to artists and t-pain was just
one of those artists i wanted to reach
out to because i just wanted his insight
with you know yeah with just
music
and
me and t-pain's relationship it started
at bonnaroo festival in 2018 like he
liked my cipher of course i grew up on
his music i grew up on rapper turned
sanga of course and then you know him
and adam developed from workaholics was
cracking jokes backstage back and forth
i loved that show yo it was like it was
like deaf comedy jam or some [ __ ] have
you ever seen them to interact it was
funny as [ __ ] that sounds amazing um i
do my set he do his set we still
cracking jokes with each other we
exchanged numbers this time the third
that's how our relationship started
and then you know i reached out to him i
was like hey i'm about to call you
because you know i changed my number i
don't know if you changed his number
um
reached out to him and i was talking to
him just picking them up and just
letting them know like yo you're a
legend i know you don't get appreciated
as much because like all the things that
happen in the industry but bruh i'm
letting you know that i appreciate you
and what you've done for me just growing
up you know what i'm saying like all the
[ __ ] you did with dj khaled of course
[ __ ] you did with rick ross all the [ __ ]
you did with plies all the [ __ ] you did
with lil wayne and even all the [ __ ]
you've done yourself even freak neat
like if you guys t pain one two punch
yeah on those khalid records yeah even
the stuff you did with kanye west yeah
come on man you know what i mean
so he would really appreciate that and i
wanted his feedback on two tracks that i
have on the album
so one of them was worse coming to worst
and i sent troubles they were two
opposites and those were like the
leading singles for me before i made any
of the other records
sent it to him and he gets back to me he
said he loved troubles and he was like
worst come the worst is fire too if i
was you i'll put both of them [ __ ]
out at the same time on different blog
sites and i was like
that [ __ ] ain't gonna work you know what
i'm saying well also
blog sites like whatever years yeah i
mean
so
he really loved the troubles record he
really liked that record so my manager
mark a year later he was like hey we
think about sending that record to t
payne to see what he's going to do with
it so i'm like all right whatever you
know you send it to most people most
people don't get back to me because it's
me right you know what i'm saying even
though they don't know me like that you
know
so
basically what happened with that was t
i'm going in the muay thai class and
t-pain texts me he's like
yo and i'm like yo
he didn't reply and i'm just like i
whatever so you know i'll call him
probably at some point then the next day
um i'm at my homie powers career which
who also um produced on this record
and you know we going over some stuff i
get a text from t-pain a dropbox folder
and i opened a folder and you know i'm
listening to it and i was like oh this
is troublesome this time the third you
know and then next thing you know his
voice comes up i'm like oh [ __ ] i start
spazzing because the man ripped it and
he gave me classic t-pain like
that everybody knows facts you know what
i'm saying he gave me t-pain t-pain he
gave me him great record and what he was
writing about was so real and i know you
felt it you know i felt that [ __ ] first
hand and i was even i even got
self-conscious a bit and i was just like
damn should i change my voice he was
like nah and then power's like nah hell
nah bro like that's the record like you
got to keep it like that
so i'm like you know what you're right
and i was feeling self-conscious because
i'm like damn t-pain ripped it but i'm
like that's the pain
you know what i'm saying no i mean
that's
he's one of them ones i mean like i
think of him and acon and like little
wayne in the run that they had when like
around the same era
and like how they were just on
everything
it was like each of them had like three
years and they just kept passing the
baton it was like a con then it was pain
and it was weighing in pain and then it
was just when it was it's every remix
everything yeah it was crazy did you
ever uh did you ever end up did you ever
do a song with dj khaled no
he never tapped in nah
i feel like he's gonna tap in though
i know he gonna tap in though i don't
even
i don't even worry i'm not even worried
about that i know he's gonna tap in and
if you don't he's sleeping
yeah cause i mean obviously
you know uh
he's he's had he's had you know born and
raised in the county and date and look
at this point [ __ ] know who the
[ __ ] i am yes i know [ __ ] know
who the [ __ ] i am
do they say anything nah they'll tell me
in person but they ain't gonna tweet
about it was on that born and raised
record it was uh born and raised in
accounting today yeah it was tricky
daddy
was rick ross was dre on it from [ __ ]
dre
no you must be thinking about brown
paper bag brown paper
that was withdrawal santana that was my
[ __ ] that [ __ ] was hard call it them
early khaled records before like i mean
khalid's still putting out back when
they had to oh my god bro there was that
one khalid video
where uh rick ross gets pulled over and
he jumps off the bridge into the water
do you remember that it was the most
ridiculous awesome like overly like
you ain't talking about we taking over
right i think so he gets pulled over and
and then
he he just says [ __ ] it and you just see
rick ross jumping off of him and it's
really him like
they didn't use the stunt double
and they film it from like all the
angles and it's rick ross just diving
into the ocean that was an era for miami
though oh it's the best that was an era
they all were on that double xl cover
was flo rider ross and khalid that [ __ ]
was so fire plies i know flies is from
fort myers but plies no
we
we claim all florida rappers we claim
everybody lives in tampa though
a lot of people you know what don't tell
them where don't tell them tell the
people where this man live man not the
people know they know i didn't know
tampa claims that [ __ ] bro that
would be at the he be at the goddamn
what's the grocery store with the gray
sandwiches in florida publix publix i
miss publix yeah me too them subs
they never had a pub so
you know it's crazy because like you can
go to roush you get the chicken tennis
up right oh you can get i mean not
anything but the chicken tenders chicken
tender sub is the best one
and
um
wawa oh they they just got it was down
out here
no not out here i'm just talking about
in florida
i know in in florida
i mean i moved there early 2014.
after the club you'd be able to go to
huawei's and get a solid meatball or
parmesan sandwich from a gas station at
like 5 a.m yeah that's true and it's
like yo
why aren't there more wawa's everywhere
the first time i heard of a wah wah was
because of ronnie j
really yeah he was the first person to
ever tell me what a wawa
it's it's kind of crazy because people
are trying to hype me up and like it's a
[ __ ] gas station no it's not just
this is just a gas station you can yeah
you can get some quality food at wawas
yeah i like wawa
yo we got to stop the interview real
quick shout out to our presenting
sponsor odd socks baby hey man listen
all i keep on my ass is odd socks draws
all i keep in my feet
socks you know why because they're the
most comfortable socks in the world and
i'm not just saying this because they
promote the podcast i'm telling you the
socks are crazy uh they got all the
licenses look they got halloween socks
they have back to the future socks
they got [ __ ] twizzler socks
old dirty bastard socks r.i.p to odb
alright they also got their draws if you
want to wear some underwear with pizza
on them whatever you need but my
favorite are the odd socks basics baby
these are just the plain boys these to
me are the most comfortable socks in the
world all right
so trust me when i say go to odd
socksofficial.com
thank me later when you go to check out
buying the most comfortable socks in the
world
get some wwe socks too i just saw a
sneak peek of the new wwe line and
they're [ __ ] insane
in [ __ ] sane
uh go to oddssocksofficial.com use the
promo code bootleg kev that's one word
together bootleg kev
we should talk to them about shortening
that bootleg cab is the promo code you
will get 20 off at checkout one more
time go to oddssoxofficial.com save 20
off using that promo code bootleg kev
let's get back to the interview what's
your favorite like uh if someone's going
to miami right and
[ __ ] yelp you have to tell them
this is kind of the
you know the the food spot that really
ain't out there like that what's the
food spot that you would like people to
go to i take people to south miami
right
oh somebody calling
hovine
i think
tech so vain for me
got hands anyway if you in miami like go
to south miami right
or you go to hialeah
it's a place called hungry bell
hungry bear yeah hungry bear and you get
these
big ass
most fire sandwich you prob probably
ever had okay i'm a sandwich guy like if
you go to south miami it's right across
the street from miami-dade okay okay you
go over there like the south campus yeah
so if you go down there go across the
street from my mbj south campus and it's
in this little plaza it's called hungry
bear go in there go get you a sandwich
they
cross everything out on the list of what
you want on your sandwich
and bruh you could say you could
like if you hella hungry
eat half that sandwich right there did
they have one in winwood
no it's a hallow i was in wynwood and
this my boy from miami took me to a
sandwich place and it was like that like
like like with the clothes you talk
about lassen
yeah it was a sandwich spot and it was
[ __ ] gas but it was in wynwood it was
like i don't know we went after rolling
louder last year and it was it was
pretty fire are you doing rolling loud
this year nope
how many rolling lives have you done i
did
from 2015 to 20
[ __ ] 2019.
were you on the uh
i didn't do the 2018 one
and i didn't do
the 20 i mean i kind of did the 2016 one
we kind of yeah i kind of did because
you know
i went there you know when you were
there i remember max invited me he
wanted me to um come out during his set
and i did that
are we sure that was 26 soon yeah it was
2016. it was on the smaller stage okay
okay yeah i can't went out for suicide
boys too
suicide boys man
them dudes is eating and then um
hey shout out to poop oh shout out to
puja we forgot to mention him when we're
talking about miami right yeah that's
true we got to mention
i just saw him um not too long ago he
cut his hair again yeah good to see puya
is good super nice guy
and fat nick i love fat nick he's just a
character he's kind of like a he's like
a walking cartoon character i always
tell him i'm like bro i'm cool with fat
nip but i'm cooler with puyo
puya yeah now pouya is a he's a beast i
feel like
he had to be influenced by what you
would you guys he says it every day yeah
very much so but he was influenced by me
and nell from like raider clan and [ __ ]
you know
the raider clan [ __ ] could have been so
crazy yeah i mean
if things didn't play out the way it did
all of us would be like
multi-millionaires right now
instead just you are
i ain't gonna even just put my name in
that ring like that
you know i'm saying i'm i'm doing well
you're doing well i'm doing well that's
all that matters man what is like this
everyone has a stupid thing they spend
money on
for me i don't buy like i don't have a
nice i just have a normal car
it's paid off i don't have a car payment
you know um
i usually buy just like
i buy basketball cards or
phoenix sun's jerseys of like any like i
have like 30 sons jerseys i don't know i
just buy stupid [ __ ] like that maybe
some jordans right what is the dumb
thing you spend money on i don't even
consider it dumb but i bought toys boys
yeah i got a toy collection you have
like a toy room
i got a toy case ah
but i just bought so how old are they
like because i have my homie dj you
remember that movie small soldiers of
course i bought those toys
like gargoyles bought those toys
gargoyles godzilla's bought those toys
um okay ultra mantega bought those toys
the old school power rangers like i
remember i remember so you got all those
you do you buy them like in the box i
buy yeah i don't open them shits at all
gotta go on ebay for that yeah i go on
ebay i try i see how much it is and it'd
be like three hundred dollars for like
the small soldiers yeah i'll be like
run it i just started to get um
some like funkos um and
i have uh
i have like i have like some lebron toys
which sounds really really stupid
compared to your toys
and i have all my old ninja turtles from
when i was a kid still in my garage i'll
be looking up the uh the burger king
dragon ball z figurines the ones that
was like silver right i'm trying to see
how much like they cost what's the most
expensive toy you have or the most
expensive toy that you like actually
cost you like the most money
man it's kind of hard to decide i forgot
um how many like how much one of my toys
costs damn it's a lot
over a thousand no i don't even know
over a thousand i think as my toys as a
whole is over a thousand probably over
two bands that's tight small soldiers
had a solid soundtrack they had a song
with bone thugs on that soundtrack that
was fire yeah that was a good movie i
didn't remember the soundtrack though i
don't know i used to be a big bone thugs
fan as a kid so like anything bone thugs
was on we would we'd buy this like oh
they're on the the batman robinson track
let's buy it oh my god small soldiers
though for people forget about that
[ __ ] movie those toys look so raw i
bet they do because the [ __ ] home
movies based on toys so like you
like even the old school toy story toys
looked hard because it felt like it was
like the same yeah buzz like the buzz
lightyear was lit woody i actually got
those in my in my toy case too you know
oh so your [ __ ] is just nostalgic yeah
got a lot of dragon ball z toys are you
a big anime guy yeah i mean i've seen
you perform i know some of your
aesthetic on your artwork all that so i
mean i can only assume um what's your
favorite what's your what's like the the
the goat anime to you
cowboy bebop cowboy bebop
that's a goat anime for me
people who think it's dragon ball z and
i love dragon ball z you know what i'm
saying but i bought my son the blu-ray
box set of dragon ball z i didn't
realize
how many episodes
were on each season
that's like a i feel like it's like more
than like most shows
but the thing with that that [ __ ] that
should just get hella turned up you know
what i'm saying
like i rewatched all nine seasons of it
during quarantine and i was like
damn this [ __ ] gave me anxiety again
like
because they'd be powering up and you
think something's gonna happen and then
they gotta go to the next episode you're
like what the hell's going on you know
i rewatched the wire during the pandemic
and kirby enthusiasm
you ever watch curb oh i love curb did
you watch this past season no i didn't
get to see the past season that's so
good but um i like curb
i never watched seinfeld though
you know
i liked seinfeld until i watched curb
and i was like seinfeld [ __ ]
curb is like what like curb is like the
absolute best version of like that type
of humor so like seinfeld was amazing
i love seinfeld but it is not [ __ ]
with curve curb
curb curb is just funny especially when
they have vivica a fox on that oh my god
hurricane katrina [ __ ] and what's crazy
is um
is uh oh boy is still um leon is still
up on the show still is with larry to
this day to the season he's still in
larry's house
so good man shout out to him um on this
album too you also got black jed talk
about that was was it track eight am i
getting it oh [ __ ]
is that track eight was it track eight
what's it called i gotta look through is
it called what you mean no it's called
ain't no way there's a song called what
you mean though no no okay i just said
it's kind of worse but it's because
there's a way
that song is crazy
it's like a real posse cut though
and you had told me all the artists on
this i didn't even realize buddy was
singing at the end
like like
crazy posse cut yeah who was on this
record okay so it's myself
jed josiah rico nasty kitty cash um
buddy robert glassman plays keys on this
uh
and powers
and buddy singing at the end
that's a hard time is that a hard song
to pull off getting
yo you would think it's a horizontal all
the moving parts yo you would think it's
a hard song to pull off but the night we
recorded that [ __ ]
it felt like it was the easiest thing
was everyone there everybody was there
oh see that's rare these days to have
that many people in the same place bro
the way the link up was crazy because i
went there for a josiah session and
josiah was working on his um song called
art of war
which at first i wasn't going right to
it and then i did the intro but i ended
up writing to it so i go outside
start writing my verse and [ __ ] right
rico nasty's next doe i didn't even know
she was in the same building rico nasty
comes out the room the same time i come
out the room to write my verse so i'm on
the couch right in out here
i'm like what the [ __ ]
like i look up and i was like oh that's
rico rico
rico i called her name three times rico
so
rico looked down finally she was like
boy oh what's up there's hell i was like
yo what's good rico we started chopping
it up
and then we go into the next room we go
into the room with josiah and sean and
all them boys
and then i was like look who i ran into
so josiah and rico chopping it up i'm
showing them how to use the kali sticks
and [ __ ] and we was talking about before
the um interview and there's an actual
video of me josiah and rico and rico
them using the kali sticks
and i i asked rico hey you trying to
jump on this song with us right
because i did my verse and then we
played it for us she was like oh hell
yeah and then we all done let's like
come over to my session and [ __ ] well we
actually took
the session to her room
to her so
to her room it was a big room right so
we go over to her session it was just
her
and david ali and her engineer
we all come in there me sean josiah and
jazz and um this other dude who pro who
produced um art of war
we're all in there just vibing next
thing you know she was like yeah i'm
going to call jig and just stand in
third she calls jig tells jed to pull up
i didn't know jed was with black at the
time or with kitty cash we just thinking
jig gonna pull up jed pulls up with
black and kitty cash we call powers
around the same time we like powers you
gotta come to this session you got to he
was doing some other [ __ ] he was like
i'm on the way he brought his laptop he
was like he was on the way he comes
through
so now there's a lot of us and now we're
seeing black and kitty cash
in the same room
next thing you know
we in there experimented this
[ __ ] uh josiah's on the couch
like turning up and [ __ ] like yelling
ain't no way we freestyling over this
beat that powers played and it had two
halves to it
so
we had you know we that's when jed i
don't know what happened but this [ __ ]
was like quincy jones that night
this man started organizing the track
like hey
hey whatever you saying right now do
that [ __ ] go in the studio record that
[ __ ] boom so josiah says ain't no way
ain't no way ain't no way on the way
like like kind of like a bridge type
[ __ ]
then he goes and tells black black we
need you to do this hook
he goes in there
does the hook like ain't no way [ __ ]
still down me after this he does that
then
he was like um rico you need to write
this like you need to write this verse
right now and then you need to go after
josiah so he started organizing this
[ __ ] and he was like denzel where you
want to go so i'm like man long as i'm
on this [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] where
i'm at right right right you get what
i'm saying because there was so many of
us buddy's not there yet but he's not
there yet but he came through like i'll
let you know where buddy came through so
we already recorded art of war me rico
and josiah right
then we recorded then we started
recording ain't no way and just putting
the pieces together so he's organizing
everybody
get i don't know ga kind of got this
experience due to the fact that they did
the revenge of the dreamers [ __ ] so yeah
i'm pretty sure yeah he was i mean that
was a very i've heard in detail about
those sessions so it makes sense he
would know how to yeah he know how to
kind of conduct everybody
then jin goes in ain't no way i ain't
going shawshank from out the [ __ ] he
does his verse and i'm sitting there
writing he gets out the booth doesn't
that what you got and then i started
spitting my verse so he was like that's
it go in there
so i go in i do my verse
and then black shows up with a bunch of
females
so we in there
black goes in started doing the oh
oh oh
oh oh oh
and then
the song's completely done
they did a third track but i went home
it was getting too late she convinced me
to stay in the studio matter of fact i
didn't even get the kitty cash part he
was like kitty
there's a bridge there's like a little
part right here we need you to talk [ __ ]
and kitty goes in there kills it one
take wow
you know what i'm saying
and then after that
i go home they made one more track that
night
and they sent ain't no way to me
but originally
we wanted rico to have it
that was supposed to be rico's record
but david was like you know it's all
fair game whoever wants it could have it
david ali is my guy and to be honest
with you i didn't want no features for
this album the only feature was t-pain
that was the only one i allowed right
but when it came down to the final
stages
and nobody was claiming this record
like it was going to be hard for on
powers to clear it you know i'm saying
rico didn't want the record even though
i felt like it fit for her right
like
i was like my manager was like why don't
we just put this record on the album and
i was just like i was on the fence about
it at first because i'm like how the
[ __ ] we gonna get all this [ __ ] cleared
so many different moving parts so many
people different labels different
management oh yeah and we all know each
other though right
and so we was of course was going to
make it work
so we go to electric lady and i finished
the little half i added more to my verse
because it was short it was the same
same length as um
jizz verse
i added more to it and robert glasper
started adding his like
keys over it
next thing you know the song was
completed
and that's how that arm song came about
you didn't tell me how buddy got on it
oh buddy shows up and then he just ended
up
did the same [ __ ] that's so crazy that
like because we don't hear that those
kind of sessions anymore
especially that many people like it's
always some emailing that should sound
like there was no email
all in person and there's pictures and
videos to prove that all of us was there
that night recording this track
tell me about um
you know
you have a crazy discography
um
how many plaques do you have
three three plaques that's big um
independently yeah as i say independent
i mean no i mean that's huge um
your discography is very uh diverse it's
very vast uh what is your
if i had to ask you what your favorite
album is
it's probably gonna be this one
excluding this one how about that
excluding this one yeah [ __ ] can't tell
you bro
i don't really got like a favorite album
like i hate looking at my old work
what is the song that you hear that's
popular of yours or that you hate to
perform because it's like so old and
you're like i'm so
i've evolved so much past this but the
fans [ __ ] love it
i mean i would say ultimate but i i love
that song it's [ __ ] great you know
like i would say clock cobain but i love
that song too i like ricky but i love
that song too and those are my hits
but um one song that i like i don't feel
confident performing but i love it so
much because it's my favorite song that
i ever made is this life okay from
imperial is it like um
is it weird to like when you put a track
list together obviously every time you
put a new album out you're like when you
go on tour you have to change up your
you switch up your track list is it kind
of hard like
dropping some records that you've been
performing for some years like i'm kind
of getting rid of some of my kids on
this tour yeah i mean at first it's hard
and then we like we would put those
records back in and then when the crowd
doesn't move because they don't know it
we take them right back out so it's like
almost like an always evolving play like
track list yeah when you're when you're
a lot when you do your tours are you
going to be torn for this album oh of
course yeah i mean i don't know man some
people are weirded out by covet still
and
give a [ __ ] i caught call it twice twice
was it the omicron
was it the og coveted first nah i didn't
get the og covey i didn't get the killer
cove i don't know okay thank god but nah
i got on covet last year in july on july
4th actually
didn't even know i just thought the [ __ ]
was allergies and i was moving around
jogging all types of [ __ ] actually one
of the tracks on this album mental
i wrapped that while i had kovit and i
didn't even know
kova track yeah that was the covet track
did you vax that thing up as juvenile
would say did i vex that thing did you
see the juvenile vex that thing did you
see that did you see the visual you
didn't see the music video they paid
juvenile to do no
oh my god it's so good
juvenile did a remix of back that ass up
and he called it backs that thing up
and they did a music video oh my god
it was like a juvie juvie
backs that thing up i swear it's it's
act it was probably one of my favorite
things to come out of the pandemic was
the fact that juvenile did that i was
just like this i don't know what to
think about this but i'm just glad it
happened
it kind of sucks kind of sad but you
know oh my god
when pandering goes wrong because it was
like a government thing you know they're
like oh they're like yo
how can we get minorities to get
vaccinated you know what
juvenile
yeah
hey man back that isn't something that's
far fetched they got me to stop tell
[ __ ] to stop vaping
i mean
yeah vaping's probably not the greatest
thing for you yep and so is covet that's
not the greatest thing for you either so
it is what it is when you say they got
you did you do a campaign for that yeah
i had to keep it up for a few months and
[ __ ] and then it was like why would you
do a campaign of no vaping i was like
well [ __ ] i was already telling
[ __ ] stop vaping for free might
as well get the bag
yeah vaping's bad and it's not
far-fetched from what i was already
telling [ __ ] it's not like i
was just out the blue just being like
hey you stopped vaping do you have a
friend that vapes like like a serious
vapor like it was my own booking agent i
got him to stop vaping and they won't
like like if you have a friend that's
like a hardcore vapor it's like it's
like attached to them like
it's like the big rig with a little
thing i know people that are still vape
like one of my i ain't gonna name his
name but like
yeah he'd be vaping i'd be like man that
should be smelling like cotton candy i
was like man get this [ __ ] out of here
dog i feel like one of those big vape
rigs
a fox racing t-shirt some cargo shorts
some dc shoes oh my god man um
just a busted down
black and white trucker hat
an icp plan
when i think of vapors that's what i
think of oh dawg
hey so look the album is out march 25th
yep
the 25th
uh why the break down the title because
the title is is is yeah it's a lot okay
the whole thing with the whole title
melt my eyes see a future when i first
made that title it was supposed to come
out after taboo and i just thought like
i
i made this long ass title it sound fire
that's all i thought it was i was like
damn if i was thinking of a fire name or
album what i call it and i was like no
my eyes see your future i was like [ __ ]
that [ __ ] sounds hard but
as i started working on the album it was
pretty much about awareness at a point
and then i was like but i'm not gonna
name an album awareness
yeah that's just like that's whack as
[ __ ] like i ain't gonna name my album
awareness be a terrible album name he's
like awareness we need to be aware like
shut up
like you know what i'm saying right
you've already made people aware to stop
vaping yeah awareness was done exactly
so
when i made
so when i started working on it more
it was more so about myself and it's
discovering who i am and you know like a
self-discovery type of thing and flaws
and everything what i'm good at and what
i'm not good at what i need to work on
what i don't need to work on you know
and
it just became about melting the
perception of who
of what people thought i was
all right you know because during the
quarantine you know before that before
we all had to isolate people were
telling me yo you're the greatest rapper
or you're this or you're that or you're
a great performer or you're the best
rapper all time or you this but the
moment quarantine happened
all that [ __ ] did not exist
what do you mean that [ __ ] didn't exist
you're just getting
like praises praise
so when people wasn't telling me who
denzel curry was then who are you who
the [ __ ] am i exactly
that's real if you yeah because if
that's always happening because you're
always out you're always running around
you're always seeing people
you can kind of just live off of that
yeah and you living off your own high
yeah you're smelling your own hot you're
smelling it yeah no it's real you know
roses a bit and you can
exist in that way
until you can't until it's all gone and
then once it's all gone you are
completely on a human level yep with
everybody you're on the same playing
field
you know what i'm saying anything could
happen so
once i got to that point where i was
like who am i it just took two years to
figure out and like do a little
soul-searching and self-discovery
with the time i did have so the pandemic
was great for you personally personal
growth wise hell yeah i think i mean i
think i feel like i still got [ __ ] i
need to work on of course
you're never gonna not have [ __ ] you
should work on no one's ever gonna be
perfect but as in being a um totally
perfect person i'm not gonna be that
being a totally flawed person i'm not
gonna be that either
that's fair well shout out to my guy i
appreciate you finally pulling up man
i'm glad to be here anytime man just let
me know when you need me to come back
cause i'll come back the album is crazy
i was saying like i mean i've listened
to pretty much every album this year
it's like up there for best time of the
year i mean i know we're only a quarter
of the way through the year but it's an
amazing body of work man right so
congrats oh this been on my mind um just
for florida rappers 454 make sure y'all
check that [ __ ] out too okay
let's get it out there four five four
yeah four five four that's i'm i'm a
peep there it is
boom
and
damn is that it that's all i don't know
what else [ __ ]
i always gotta i gotta i gotta end with
this you wanna rap hell no no no i just
wanted to end with like are we still
recording yeah all right
if you not a denzel curry fan
for whatever reason if you think i'm
trash
if you think i'm ass if you think i'm
garbage
listen to this [ __ ] album
and i bet you i bet all my money that
you would like this [ __ ]
if you were denzel curry fan and you
left for whatever reason
bump this [ __ ] album because you're
gonna be a denzel curry fan again
that's what i believe there's no doubt
in my mind there ain't gonna be no skips
on this [ __ ] and you know this
that's what i'm leaving off zero skips
14 tracks zero skips zero skips it's two
sevens i'm channeling god twice
supreme mathematics there it is